Guten Tag, mein Name ist Bulur. Ich bin die die Stabende Erstein auf der Situation und würde gerne das Erstein mit Ihnen führen.
Ist das Ordnung für Sie?
Ja, ist Ordnung.
Okay, so als werde ich ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Person stellen, dann direkt Ihre aktuellen Beschwerden übergehen. Wie heißen Sie dann?
Mein Name ist Hans Maia.
Hans Maia.
Herr Maia, können Sie Ihren Fond um ein Haumus geben?
Hans, H, A, N, S, Maia, M, A, Y, E, R.
E, R. Okay, Maia.
Herr Maia, wie heißen Sie?
Ich bin ungefähr 40.
Ungefähr 40. Okay, wann ist genau geworden?
29.05.1985.
5.1985.
5.1985. Okay.
Ja.
Und wissen Sie, wie groß Sie sind?
Ja, ich bin 1,70 Meter, Frau Doktor.
1,70 Meter. Okay. Und wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ja, 78 Kilo.
78?
Ja.
Wie heißen Sie?
Herr Müller.
Herr Maia, können Sie Ihren Geburtstatus wiederholen?
Entschuldigung, ich habe falsch gedacht.
29.05.1985.
25.80. Okay.
25.80. Okay. Was für Sie heute sonst?
Ja, Frau Doktor, habe ich Gelenkschmerzen.
Mein rechts Fuß und rechts Fußgelenk tut weh.
Rechts Fußgelenk tut weh. Okay.
Seit wann haben Sie Gelenkschmerzen?
Seit gestern Abend, Frau Doktor.
Ich habe gestürzt und mein Fußgelenk ungeknickt.
Zuerst war es nicht schlimm, aber gestern Abend wird es schlimm.
Ja, es ist schlimm geworden.
Jetzt kann ich mich nicht belasten.
Es ist sehr schlimm, Frau Doktor.
Haben Sie gestern gestürzt?
Ja, gestern Abend.
Beim Waldlaufen, ich laufe regelmäßig.
Beim Laufen habe ich gestürzt, dann mein Sprunggelenk umgeknickt.
Es war schmerzhaft, aber jetzt ist es schlimmer.
Okay. Sind Ihre Schmerzen irgendwo hinaus?
Ja, in den Waden und Zählen streicht mein Schmerz aus.
Wie stark ist Ihr Schmerz auf einer Schmerzskala von 1 bis 10?
Wobei 1 ist sehr leicht und 10 ist ein starkes Schmerz?
Es ist schlimm, Frau Doktor. Ich kann mich nicht belasten. Vielleicht 8.
8, okay.
Könnten Sie Ihre Schmerzen bis zum Ende des Gesprächs aushalten oder brauchen Sie sofort ein Schmerzmittel?
Ja, heute Morgen habe ich ein Schmerzmittel angenommen. Deswegen möchte ich nicht.
Okay. Was haben Sie angenommen? Welche Mittag?
Ibuprofen habe ich angenommen.
Aber nicht geholfen?
Ja, nicht geholfen. Ich kann sagen, ein bisschen.
Okay. Könnten Sie Ihren Unfall oder Ihren Gestürs ein bisschen beschreiben?
Haben Sie Schwindelung?
Nein, während des Laufens habe ich gestorben.
Es gab einen Stein und ich habe gestorben und mein Sprunggelenk umgeknickt.
Okay. Haben Sie das Bewusstsein verloren?
Nein, nein. Aber zuerst war ich Schwindel bei vielen wegen Schmerzen. Aber jetzt habe ich keine Schwindelung.
Okay.
Haben Sie eine Zählstörung oder Hörenstörung?
Nein, nein. Hörenstörung, ja.
Fühlen Sie beim Ihren Rechtebein oder Rechtefuss oder Rechte-Seyn, Tabhalsgefühl oder Kriben?
An einigen Stellen habe ich Tabhalsgefühl wie ein Meiselauf.
Es ist komisch, aber vielleicht wegen geschwollenen Gelenken.
Es ist schlimm geworden. Mein Sprunggelenk ist dick.
Okay. Ist Ihren Bein oder Ihren Gelenk Rötung oder Überwarmung ausgefallen?
Ja, ein bisschen Rot und es gibt auch Bluterguss.
Außerhalb gibt es Bluterguss und es ist rot geworden. Rot und dunkelrot.
Okay. Ist es auch überwarmt?
Ja, ein bisschen überwarmt.
Okay.
Kann ich meinen Sprunggelenk bewegen? Es ist sehr schmerzhaft. Mein Bewegung ist eingeschränkt.
Können Sie Ihren Bein hoben oder strecken? Nein.
Ja, ich kann hoben. Was meinen Sie? Ich verstehe nicht.
Können Sie Ihren Bein hoben?
Ja, ich kann hochlegen, aber ich kann nicht meinen Sprunggelenk bewegen.
Okay. Ja, ich verstehe. Haben Sie Übigkeit?
Ja, ein bisschen. Ich denke, es ist sehr schmerzhaft. Aber ich habe keine Übigkeit.
Okay. Haben Sie eine offene oder Blutende Wunde?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Okay. Haben Sie Probleme mit Nachschweiß?
Nein. Aber gestern Abend konnte ich nicht schlafen. Wegen Schmerzen.
Ich habe den Eispack aufgetragen. Ganz nachts. Und ich habe meinen Sprunggelenk hochgelogen.
Aber es ist schlimm geworden. Deswegen habe ich die Internetaufnahmen.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Wie ist Ihr Apathet?
Seit gestern Abend habe ich nichts gegessen. Ich habe Schmerzen, Frau Doktor. Es ist sehr schmerzhaft.
Ja, ich verstehe. Aber Sie brauchen nicht eine Schmerzfetale.
Aber ich habe heute Morgen angenommen. Es ist gefährlich, denke ich. Ich habe manchmal Magenschmerzen.
Okay. Ja, ich verstehe Sie. Aber Sie können Ihre Schmerzen lindern. Deswegen habe ich diese Fragen gestellt.
Aber unser Gespräch wird sehr kurz nach diesem Gespräch. Ich werde Sie einschmerzen.
Haben Sie Atemnot?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Okay. Haben Sie Herzrasen, Herzstorben oder Herzglaufen?
Nein, ich habe keine Herzprobleme, Frau Doktor.
Okay. Haben Sie irgendwelche Begleitsymptomen mit diesen Schmerzen oder diese Beschwerden?
Mein Bein und mein Fuß tut weh. Nur mein Bein und mein Fuß tut weh. Ich habe keine anderen Probleme.
Okay. Ich verstehe. Leiden Sie an irgendwelchen chronischen Erkrankungen?
Ja, ich leide an Asthma seit vielleicht 20 Jahren. Und auch leide ich an Magenentzündung Gastritis.
Deswegen leide ich auch an Bluthochdruck.
Seit wann haben Sie Bluthochdruck und Gastritis?
Gastritis seit 5 Jahren und Bluthochdruck seit 10 Jahren, Asthma seit 20 Jahren. Mit 19 Jahren habe ich an Nonhochkin Blüphoma gelitten.
Okay.
Und wurde ich mit Chemotherapie behandelt und genau geheilt.
Okay. Ja, sehr gut.
Und nehmen Sie regelmäßig Medikamente ein?
Ja, natürlich, Frau Doktor. Natürlich nehme ich Norwask, 10 mg täglich einmal.
Morgen oder Abend?
Norwask.
Morgens oder abends?
Morgens. Ich nehme Aspirin, 100 mg. Und nehme einen Spray auf. Berodual Spray.
Berodual.
Berodual, ja.
Ja, wegen Asthma. Und ich nehme manchmal Loretidin Tablet.
Loretidin Tablet?
Ja.
Bei Bedarf?
Ja, manchmal nämlich. Besonders im Frühling nämlich.
Haben Sie Allergie?
Ja, ich habe Polenallergie.
Polenallergie, ja, ich verstehe.
Welche Deserung nehmen Panteprosol ein?
20 mg. Morgens nehme ich Nüchtern.
Okay.
Sind Sie vollständig geübt?
Ja, Frau Doktor. Ich habe alle Impfungen gehabt.
Okay. Waren Sie in letzter Zeit im Ausland?
Ja, vor vier Monaten war ich im Urlaub. Im Spanien.
Spanien. Okay. Und Sie haben gesagt, Sie gerne wandern.
Und treiben Sie regelmäßig Sport?
Ja, ja. Mindestens dreimal pro Woche laufe ich.
Ich mache Natur, Frau Doktor. Ich laufe, wandere, klettere.
Mache ich alle Natur-Sport.
Okay. Herr Mayer, rauen Sie?
Ja, ich raufe gerne.
Okay. Wie oft rauen Sie?
Jeden Tag raufe ich.
Jeden Tag? Wie viele Zigaretten rauen Sie?
Ein Schachtel ungefähr.
Seit wann rauen Sie?
Seit 15 Jahren raufe ich.
15? Ja.
Okay. Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Nein, ich trinke kein Alkohol.
Haben Sie getrunkt oder nie?
Ja, einmal vielleicht. Ich erinnere mich nicht, als ich im Gymnasium war.
Ich habe probiert, aber ich trinke nicht.
Okay, sehr gut. Hatten Sie hier mal Kontakt mit Drogen?
Nein, nein. Ich bin Lehrer, Frau Doktor.
Ich habe keinen Kontakt mit Drogen.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Nein, ich bin nicht verheiratet.
Ledig? Leben Sie einen oder haben Sie einen Partner?
Ich lebe alleine.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Nein, ich bin alleine, Frau Doktor.
Okay. Gibt es in Ihrer Familie irgendwelche chronischen Erkrankungen?
Mein Vater ist vor fünf Jahren an Herzinfarkten gestorben.
Fünf Jahre?
Ich verstehe nicht.
Es tut mir sehr leid zu hören.
Meine Mutter ist wegen eines Autounfalles, als ich Kind war, gestorben.
Okay. Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe einen Bruder.
Ist er gesund?
Er hat auch Bluthochdruck.
Okay.
Genetisch ist Bluthochdruck.
Ja, Bluthochdruck kann genetisch erblich sein.
Wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Vor drei Jahren wurde ich wegen einer Meniskuserkrankung operiert.
Okay.
Noch etwas?
Nein, noch etwas.
Okay. Hermann?
Ich habe keine Kopfverletzung, Frau Doktor.
Wenn ich gestürzt habe, habe ich keine Kopfverletzung.
Okay. Welche Seite haben Sie gestürzt?
Welche Seite?
Rechtsseite.
Rechtsseite. Auf dem Arm, auf dem Hüfte oder?
Nur mein Sprunggelenk ist ungeknickt und ich bin gestürzt.
Okay.
Haben Sie andere Körperregionen Schmerzen?
Ja, in der Wade habe ich Schmerzen. Im Fuß sehe ich und besonders im Sprunggelenk.
Ich verstehe, Herr Meyer.
Ich habe keine weiteren Fragen.
Möchten Sie noch etwas hinzufügen, was ich wissen sollte?
Oder haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Ist das gefährlich, Frau Doktor? Ich bin sportlich und muss operieren?
Deshalb kann ich Ihnen leider noch keine Antwort geben.
Wir müssen ein paar Untersuchungen durchführen.
Sobald die Ergänzungen vorliegen, kann ich Ihnen genauer sagen.
Aber machen Sie sich bitte keine Sorgen.
Wir werden alle notwendigen Untersuchungen durchführen.
Und ich werde Ihnen schnell helfen.
Okay, Frau Doktor. Danke Ihnen.
Ja.
Ich habe ein paar Fragen.
Haben Sie bei der Stürmung oder Wasserlasten Probleme?
Nein, ich habe keine Probleme bei der Wasserlastung.
Haben Sie auf den Kopf gefallen?
Nein, nur mein Sprunggelenk ist verletzt.
Ich habe jetzt eine starke Schmerzen und Geschwuren.
Haben Sie beim Unfall ein Helm getragen?
Nein, ich bin wegen der Schmerzen gelaufen.
Ja, ich verstehe. Danke schön.
Können Sie Ihre Schmerzen beschreiben?
Sind diese Schmerzen durch die Hände oder ...
Ich habe ein Druckgefühl. Das ist ein steigendes Schmerzen.
Steigendes Schmerzen.
Steigendes und ein Druckgefühl.
Okay.
Alle wichtigen Fragen wurden gestellt.
Wer Sie möchten, können wir anfangen. Bitte schön.
Herr Oberarzt, ich möchte Ihnen einen neuen Patienten vorstellen.
Haben Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Ja, bitte schön.
Der Patient heißt Hans Maja. Er ist 50 Jahre alt.
Er ist 1,70 Meter groß und wiegt 78 Kilogramm.
Herr Maja ist heute bei uns.
Seit gestern Abend.
Er hat ein Druckgefühl.
Er hat ein Schmerzen.
Er hat ein Schmerzen im linken Fuß.
Er hat ein Schmerzen
im linken Fuß.
Und er hat einen Schmerz.
Er hat einen Schmerz.
Die Schmerzintensität liegt bei 8 von 10 auf der Schmerzskala.
Die Schmerzen sind gestern Abend aufgetreten
und hatten in der Mittelfracht verschlechtert.
Der Patient berichtete,
die Schmerzen sind nur besonders bei den Patienten sprügelig.
Wie ist der Unfall passiert eigentlich?
Wenn der Patient im Waden läuft,
hat er auf der linken Seite gestürzt.
Er hat umgeknickt und dann auf der linken Seite hingefallen.
Ist er nach innen oder nach außen umgeknickt?
Ich habe diese Frage nicht gestellt.
Aber bei der Körperleitung kann ich fragen.
Okay.
Nein.
Bei ihrem Arm.
Arm oder?
Beim Sprügelenkt.
Sprügelenkt, okay.
Okay.
Der Patient, der Frage nach Vertigo,
Vertigoerbrechen oder Bebusverlustsein,
wurde verneint.
Der Patient hat 600 mg Ibuprofen zu Hause genommen.
Das hat ihm ein bisschen geholfen.
Okay.
Er hat seit 5 Jahren Gastritis,
seit 20 Jahren Asthma,
seit 10 Jahren Arterielypertonie.
Bei dem Patienten wurde im Alter von 19 Jahren
eine Non-Hodgkin-Lärmform bekannt.
Er hat mit Chemotherapie behandelt.
Der Patient nimmt regelmäßig 20 mg Pantaprosol morgens,
10 mg Norvax morgens und 100 mg Acetylsalicylsäure ein.
Und bei Bedarf benutzt er Berodualspray gegen Asthma
und Larotidin Tablet bei Bedarf.
Er ist vor 10 Jahren wegen Meniskus
eine Operation durchgeführt worden.
Er ist vollständig und die Anamnese ist unauffällig.
Er ist Lehrer und er ist ledig und lebt allein.
Er hat keine Kinder.
Er arbeitet als Lehrer und er rache
und trinkt keine Alkohol.
Er trinkt keine Alkohol und Drogenkonsum wurde vermeint.
In der Familienanamnese wird angegeben,
sein Vater ist vor 5 Jahren
mit einem Myokardialinfarkt verstorben.
Und seine Mutter ist wegen eines Autounfalles verstorben.
Seine Mutter ist wegen eines Autounfalles verstorben.
Er hat einen Bruder und er leidet an arterieller Hypertonie.
Die Anamnistischen Angaben deuten am ehesten
eine sprunggelenkte Fraktur.
Dafür spricht die Bewegung
und die Hautfarbeänderung des Umgebungsgelenk.
Das ist der Fachbegriff für diese Farbeveränderung.
Ja, ich weiß.
Hämatome.
Hämatome und...
Dollar, color...
Nein, Hämatome und Bewegung eingeschränkt.
Bewegung, Einschränkungen.
Bewegung, Einschränkungen, Kribbern.
Diese Symptome sprechen für eine Gelenkfraktur.
Und zur Abklärung der Beschwerden
sollten als Differenzialdiagnosen in Betra kommen.
Eine Bandsprählung oder...
Bandschriss können wir sagen.
Oder Bandschrubtur.
Bandschrubtur.
Und eine...
...Ellokation.
Okay.
Zur weiteren...
Zur Abklärung der Beschwerden
sollten die folgenden Maßnahmen durchgeführt werden.
So als würde ich der Patient stationär aufnehmen.
Und...
...Mittelparameter überwachen.
Und eine Zugang legen.
Eine Zugang legen.
Um die ausreichende Flüssigkeit zu verbringen.
Und ein Schmerzmittel verbreiten.
Um die Stabilisierung zu verlegen.
Danach werde ich eine Röntgenaufnahme des Gelenks veranlassen.
Um meine Verdachtdiagnose bestätigen.
Oder die andere mögliche Pathologie ausüben.
Gegebenenfalls würde ich eine CT veranlassen.
Würden Sie ein MRT durchführen?
Ja, ein MRT kann denken.
Aber in diesem Fall die Patienten haben...
...aber ein MRT kann ein bisschen mehr Zeit...
...dauern.
Und wir planen eine MRT.
Deshalb können wir eine Röntgen- oder CT-Ansage...
...eine schnelle Antwort machen.
Warum kann ein MRT wichtig für diese Patienten?
Ein MRT zeigt uns alle weiche Gewebezustand.
Deshalb beim Fraktor.
Und ein Fraktor kann verschiedene Verletzungen machen.
Deshalb würde ich die anderen Pathologien im Weiche Gewebe...
...zum Beispiel Tenden oder Bandligament suchen.
Deshalb kann ich eine MRT denken.
Haben Sie schon DMS gehört?
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung?
DMS?
Was meinen Sie?
DMS Untersuchung ist sehr wichtig bei diesen Patienten.
Durchblutung, Motorik und Sensorik.
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung, die neurologische Untersuchung ist wichtig.
Und ich habe schon gesagt, dass Durchblutung sehr wichtig ist. Warum?
Durchblutung, genau.
Der Patient kann einen Schock machen.
Würden Sie die Pellizepulze abtasten?
Natürlich.
Ich würde die Pellizepulze abtasten.
Genau.
Ich würde die Arteriepupilte abtasten.
Okay.
Ich würde alle Reflexe kontrollieren.
Und ich würde...
...Parasthesien oder Hypostasien beurteilen.
Welche Therapiemöglichkeiten haben Sie bei diesen Patienten?
Sie haben schon den Patienten stationär aufgenommen?
Stationär aufgenommen und eine orthopädische Kostin anfordert.
Dann sollte sich die Verdachtdiagnose bestätigen.
Ich schlage die folgende Therapie vor.
Eine Operation planen.
Okay. Vor der Operation, was machen Sie zuerst?
Ich würde den Patienten an der Anarchie verbreiten.
Und ich würde die Stabilisierung des Gelenks machen.
Oder ich würde das Gelenk stabilisieren.
Und...
Schonung, Kühlung und Hochlagerung sind sehr wichtig bei diesen Patienten.
Chemias adaptierte Analgesie, Sie haben schon gesagt.
Und dann Operation. Kennen Sie die Operation?
Sie meinen, oder?
Ja, genau.
Ja, mit Metall.
Eigentlich habe ich nicht die Details wissen.
Okay. Gut, das ist genug, ich glaube.
Okay, danke schön, Herr Oberst.
Herr Thiebmann, können Sie die Aufnahme aufnehmen?
Okay, ich habe es nicht verstanden.
Ich habe es nicht verstanden.
Hallo Herr Oberst, mein Name ist Erdem.
Ich habe einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen.
Ich würde den Patienten vorstellen. Haben Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Ja bitte.
Es handelt sich um Herrn Hans Mayer.
Hans Mayer ist 14 Jahre alt und 1,70 Meter groß und 78 Kilogramm schwer.
Er hat über Einstein geschlupst.
Er ist in diesem Moment schwer geworden.
Er wurde mit 8,5 Cent auf eine Schmerzskala bewertet.
Ich habe die Einmalige von 600 Milligramm Ibuprofen ein bisschen verbessert.
Ein wenig.
Die Schmerzen würden unter den Schenkeln ausgetragen werden.
Die Frage nach Kopfverletzung sind Kopf- und Emesis-Furde verneint.
Die vegetative Anamnese ist folgende bekannt.
Inapetens, Insomni, Neusea und Neusea.
Die Frage nach Schweiß, Emesis, Dispnoe, Sinnkopf und Tachikardi-Furde verneint.
An Führerkrankungen, Nante, seit 20 Jahren bestehende Asthma, seit 5 Jahren bestehende Gastritis, seit 10 Jahren arteriale Hypertonik, seit 10 Jahren non-hochgen Lymphome.
Die Chemotherapie ist verhandelt.
Seit 3 Jahren wurde bei den Patienten eine menüsge risse Operation durchgeführt.
Im Wesentlichen der Medikation nimmt er Pantoprosol 20 mg einmal täglich und Norvask 10 mg einmal täglich, Aspirin 100 mg.
Ein Sprich gegen Wegen Asthma heißt Berotwald.
Bei Bedarf Loratadin ein.
Er reagiert allergisch auf Polen.
Er raucht eine Schachtel täglich Zigaretten seit 50 Jahren.
Er trinkt keinen Alkohol.
Der Druckkonsum wurde verneint.
Im Besuch der Familienanamnese teilt er mit, dass der Vater vor 5 Jahren an Myokartinfarkt gestorben ist.
Die Mutter hatte einen Autounfall und deswegen ist sie gestorben.
Der Bruder hat eine arterielle Hypertonik.
Er tritt regelmäßig Sport.
Er will zum Beispiel laufen, wandern.
Er ist ledig und lebt allein und hat keine Kinder.
Ich gehe von einer Verdachtstheatomathose auf Gelenkfraktur aus.
Dafür sind die Patienten typische Symptome ausgestochen.
Die Patienten haben Schwellungen, Hämatome, Cola und eine eingeschränkte Bewegung im rechten Fußgelenk.
Er hat einen Unfall und der Patient hat über einen Stein gestorben.
Er spricht für die Gelenkfraktur.
Meine Anschlussweise als Differentialdiagnose ist eine überschenkelnde Faktur.
Ich werde die Patienten stationär aufnehmen.
Ich werde die Witterparameter überwachen.
Dann werde ich eine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen.
Dann werde ich die Patienten auf die arterielle Pulse abtasten.
Außerdem werde ich die Schwellungen, Hämatome, Cola und eine eingeschränkte Bewegung durchführen.
Neben der körperlichen Untersuchung werden Laberunterzüge ein Symbol sein, um die Patienten und die Patienten zu diagnostizieren.
Dabei werde ich ein kleines Blutbild, die Anzündungsparameter und die CRP bestimmen lassen.
Dann werde ich eine Röntgen des Gelenks und der Unterschenkel veranlassen, um die möglichen Frakturen zu beurteilen.
Dann werde ich die Patienten auf die körperliche Untersuchung beurteilen und die Operation zu planen.
Wenn es nötig ist, würde ich eine MRT durchführen, um weiße Gewerbe und andere Probleme zu beurteilen.
Sollte ich meine Verdachtstherapie bestätigen, würde ich die Therapiemaßnahmen durchführen.
Ich werde den Patienten eine Venous-Sugang legen und eine Flüssigkeit und Analgesik einleiten.
Dann werde ich eine orthopäische Konsul anordnen, um meine Therapie zu optimieren.
Wenn sie mit dieser vorgehenden Einweise einverstanden sind,
werde ich mit der geplanten Untersuchung die Anzündungsprobe beurteilen.
Herr Kollegen, in welcher Situation möchten Sie MRT?
Wenn Sie keine Fraktur diagnostizieren, möchten Sie die MRT nicht beurteilen.
Würden Sie in diesem Fall eine Dublix-Sonographie machen?
Sie haben recht, um die Gefäße der Beine und der Gelenk zu beurteilen.
Haben Sie eine Vermutung, in welche Knochen gebrochen?
Ich bin nicht sicher, ob das eine oder andere ist.
Ich habe nicht gehört.
Lateral-Malliol oder innen-Malliolfraktur?
Ist das möglich?
Ich verstehe.
Haben Sie eine andere Behandlungsmethode?
Ja, ich weiß.
Es gibt eine andere Methode.
Aber ich habe keine Ahnung.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Empfehlen Sie eine Krankschreibung?
Ja, natürlich.
Ich empfehle den Patienten mindestens 6 Wochen Krankschreiben.
Kontrollieren Sie die Tetanus-Impfungen?
Ja, Sie haben recht.
Ich muss Tetanus-Impfungen kontrollieren.
Aber ich muss den Patienten fragen.
Hat der Patient Kopfhörungen?
Nein.
Der Patient hat gesagt, dass er keinen Kopfhörungen hat.
Hat er andere Körperteile?
Der Physiker hat gefragt.
Aber ich weiß, dass der Patient keine andere Verlassungen hat.
Vielen Dank, Herr Kollegen.
Wir treffen morgen wieder.
Ich werde gerne fragen.
Vielen Dank.
Du bist da?
Ja, ich habe gesagt, dass ich dich sehe.